[Music]
what were some of your top
uh dream jobs as a kid pirate
pirate i want to be a pilot pilot in a
pirate
and i also want to be a firefighter and
i want to be a doctor
i want to be a lot of things when i was
a really little girl yeah and i wanted
to be able to be a chef
a chef i wanted to be a food critic and
you kind of are
i wanted to be i want to work in fifth
grade i wanted to be you knew what that
was
my thing for a long time was being the
the tester for the roller coasters at
six flags
because drew carey and his show because
i used to watch a show a lot when i was
a kid
that was his dream job and i'm like i'm
stealing your dream job i want
i wanted to be a lawyer at one point in
time because i knew they made money
money is good but nothing else other
than that because their job is really
are you yeah yeah you probably could
yeah but the food the model food critic
i remember writing it down i was like i
want to do both because they're the
opposites
you should still do that i i feel like
you haven't done that
that's a
but yeah when i was younger i was like i
want to get paid to eat i just think
that's the coolest like
what to pay me to eat food yes that's
true you make money to
to pay for food in order to eat but it's
like reversed i love it i like it nikki
bangs
mukbangs oh oh there we go hey that's
casual
or bling or blaze bangs we got to go
with blaze there's too many nicki's okay
yeah
so okay something with blades yeah think
of something think about considering
nikki bangs though for a little bit
i'm pretty sure there's somebody already
on pornhub with that name
oh i didn't think of it in that
direction i'm sorry i uh
i was in the wrong brain you know how
many clicks i would get if i was like
oh yeah never mind if you were going to
be on board humber's nikki bangs
no blades is good i think it's doing
well up there forks and blades
porks and blades yeah blades and forks
and fork and blades
forking blades see there we go there's
another pornhub title
[ __ ] blades all right did any one of
you guys
ever wanted to be a spy oh yeah hell
yeah
an operative bro an operative like james
bond style i actually would spy
on people yeah you were you were a
hacker
yeah dude i remember when harriet this
bike came out and all my friends and me
spied on each other for like
harriet the spy was harry what do you
mean by spying each other i don't know
we're just like watching each other and
then we're like writing in our little
notebooks about each other detective
he's still looking at me i'm still
looking at him basically
for like nine days wait go go gadget
wasn't go go gadget
inspector gadget go go gadget arm dude
my best friend and i we had
uh we created this wheel thing where it
had the alphabet and then it had symbols
and then we would
use that wheel to write notes to each
other like letters
like cryptic language like a lot of work
did you guys
really spy on your neighbors as a kid
i got bored doing it though being tom
spy or like just my mom bought me this
you know the
lame ass yeah telescope so then at first
i was like
looking across the street and then i
would look like
into the backyards of my neighbors and i
was like i need to get a better look
and then i would climb up the fence and
i would walk
from neighbor to neighbors you see this
little kid just walking
on top of the brick wall yeah and i'm
just like looking like this
excuse me can you open the curtains
please i can't see
you can't see it's not nice no matter
what i imagine i imagine you're right
against the window with the telescoping
against the window and you're like hello
i used to jump tapping into my i used to
jump into my neighbor's backyards and
play
on their jungle gym and stuff dude like
i did that i did that i was like
the kid that was all over the
neighborhood they ever tell you anything
yeah did they hate you were they like
get off my lawn
i mean you're like what six or whatever
and they're just like hey there's a
[ __ ] kid here
no i think about it my aunt used to take
us to go hop in people's pools
that's so funny yeah my aunt you said
yeah
i don't know if she knew them but for us
it was like oh we're gonna go hop into
someone's backyard also she used to go
take us to go play at walmart
random question did she also day drink
during any of this sounds like a day
drinker
let's go play that wall but my whole
family was day drinking so that's
problem i was like listen i wasn't
around the most stable humans at the
time
they're like you know what midnight
let's go play
at walmart right now they would let all
the kids run around walmart and play
with the ball we were
ghetto dang my uncle used to take us to
uh
costco for free snacks my aunt used to
yeah it's like let's go get snacks and
we would get snacks and we would leave
my aunt would open up the packages and
eat them before she got to the cash
register that was my dad's too
stop to this day it makes me cringe i'm
like don't
you touch the packaging but he buys them
though yeah you just put the empty
wrapper on empty wrapper on the thing
and skinny check it out and she would
just be like
oh nobody cares just open it but you
know the grocery stores now have that
i've seen that at grocery stores where
they have like this whole section of
like
drinks and snacks and it actually has a
sign they're like oh enjoy it while you
shop
see the last part because people were
just grabbing it off the shelves and
eating it
yeah they realized how trash we all were
yeah
but yeah so back to the spy thing uh i
have an article here where they
interviewed two different spies and they
worked for the cia and they were
operatives as well
and uh they break down what it takes to
be a spy and it's actually numerous
it's surprisingly less james bondy yeah
it's more tinker taylor soldier spy
i was like oh cool it's a real spy movie
turned it off
is it more like being a stalker it's
like yeah you're just sitting in a room
with [ __ ] old equipment
and you're waiting for people to talk on
the phone a whole bunch of cigarettes
while you're doing that
yes and you're just waiting you're just
there's no sexy ladies trying to capture
you
um but yeah so uh the sexual innuendo
name
exactly did anybody go through any laser
lasers no lasers
that's what i was trying to say earlier
catherine jones going through those
lasers i forgot about so hot
entrapment entrapment yeah i remember
watching that
and as as a little girl i would be going
under my brother's crib
trying to do like the full that's
probably sexy as hell
as an eight-year-old
it's the chair i'm in the chair well it
wasn't he
[ __ ] and he was like oh that was being
watched
nice oh gosh
oh i was not i'm definitely not graceful
we are not
making it through any of those lasers
i'm walking everything going off we all
died
all of us are dead but yeah so uh
in order to be a spy you'd uh
in order to be a spy you got to go
through a background check and they look
in the past 10 years of your life
in the past 10 years you may or may not
make it you would look at like your
entire life i'm surprised
just 10. maybe because people change
listen yeah if they believe if the
if spies can change then people can
change on twitter too can't they
that's true is there a ten year now we
gotta put a tenure on it well i don't
know the twitter it lasts forever i feel
like there's
nothing that escapes twitter what i said
at 14 will still haunt me when i'm 45.
yeah very true but yeah another test
that you have to go through is the
polygraph test
along with personal interviews and so
it's very extensive they have to know
everything about your life for the past
10 years and then once you do get past
the interview
uh section of the uh the process
uh they take you to a place called the
farm
and it's a compound in it's in virginia
right virginia yes it's a compound
cia yeah it's the cia like the training
facility and that's where
they will learn paramilitary skills and
more importantly how to spot
assess and recruit foreign spies and
this is what they say is the main thing
they do
like using military skills that's kind
of like
the side stuff the main thing is
actually talking to people
assessing them and trying to figure out
if they can work for you as
a uh as a as they uh an asset yes that's
the word fun fact
i know some um special military guys and
i heard this story
where they were at undisclosed
developing country
parting up and they met some guys that
speak english at the club
and then they're like let's go hang out
and then luckily
the guy in the morning um got like
what he called like a hangover and he's
like i can't go out today and then those
guys
were actually double agents working for
us government but also for that other
government because they were paying
really well
and they got national loyalty and put
into the uh
military jail the military jail when
you're be when you're a trader to this
country
it's a whole different game when you're
a military guy first off
when you're a military guy going to
military jail it's already hard because
you don't get the regular
like you waive your constitutional
rights rights yeah you're you're like
you're like yeah and then when you're a
trader even crazier
that guantanamo bay [ __ ] is real yeah
wow
that's why they want to keep that going
because they don't have to
uh adhere to the concept you're
constitutional
so it's i've heard of it so we have a
little spot next to cuba right you know
where guantanamo
bay is it's like a um it's a it's a it's
an area where
america tried to kind of invade cuba or
whatever but we have a little base there
so
yeah and then from there it's almost
like
it's not america so the the law american
laws don't exist there yeah because it's
not obvious it's not unlike
the actual country yeah but we have a
like a prison holding place there that's
where we send all of our
terrorists or whoever and then when we
did like the patriot
act or whatever like it allowed us to uh
you know that's when they were like yeah
they're doing waterboarding and torture
tactics and all these things to get
information
and not just there either we have black
sites all over the world where we do
that [ __ ]
wow but the whole point is to keep them
out of the u.s because then you don't
have to give them
rights yeah but what they found out too
is that a lot of people that they
call as these terrorists like some of
them
are just innocent people and then um you
know if you're getting tortured you get
uh scared and you just can't take it
anymore so you start lying and giving up
information
and so there's they just found out that
a lot of it was just useless
informations they're just torturing
people for no reason oh [ __ ]
and they've studied it too they showed
it's super ineffective yeah torture it
doesn't
provide any real information but also
the military need to
um have numbers to report to be like
all right we got 10 notorious terrorists
but then the uh our police
yeah the dea all these guys they do this
all the [ __ ] time they'll be like
there's this big [ __ ] drug lord you
know his name is pablo escobar or
whatever and this is his whole
organization
and this and that but a lot of the times
it's just fabricated to make somebody
look
even bigger than what they are so it's
like look at we got we got this big guy
we could scapegoat this guy while the
cia literally runs drugs
like through like all every border right
right yeah it's pretty crazy that's so
crazy yeah so here
is uh lindsay she is a
uh cia operative from 1999 to 2000. she
was in the room
smoking cigarettes all day huh yes and
listening and spying on people and going
to clubs and
and talking to people and just trying to
get uh different assets to work for her
in different countries
so she actually was the double 07
[ __ ] the dudes
yeah she she's the the femme fatale yeah
and sucking
have you heard of uh uh honey pot
operations oh yeah oh no
operations is exactly like what we saw
in the spy movies where
a girl is coming in and seducing the spy
but she's actually
right right this is
she's the real life angelina jolie and
then here is uh
matthew this guy's matthew this is this
is a target yeah
he was a target this is the real life
james bond actually
this is the real life daniel craig right
here he's got good ass skin
he doesn't have good attitude that's
true it's baby skin
he is hydrated anybody that looks like
an egg
is like legit he gives me creepy vibes
like he gives me vibes like he's done
some [ __ ]
and scenes he speaks multiple languages
though
no it's the eyes i could see and i could
see it is it because he's looking like
this
he's seen some [ __ ] he's like i remember
that's one night yeah
he looks like the lack of smile it's
just like one night he looks like he has
a dark secret
he speaks multiple languages and then
the next part
next like he's like he's actually a
really good person he's like
here's my children i stole that true
yeah
interestingly enough that they said the
hardest thing about being a secret spy
was uh keeping it a secret that was the
number one thing like aside from like
doing all the paramilitary stuff being i
had to look away and then he's looking
at me
oh yeah right isn't he creepy i caught
myself
staring i'm like that's why we couldn't
be surprised because all i'd want to do
is talk about it me too
oh i don't yeah i know i suck at secrets
hi i'm steve i'm [ __ ] fine
you literally need to drop off the grid
like you have to be you have to
disappear you can't tell your family
can't tell i mean and you if you do tell
them like saying you're going to
business trip or whatever you
literally have to lie to their faces
dude cut to me in a bar i'm like i'm a
[ __ ] spy shot's on me
they're like this guy again he comes
here every week says the same story
every time
he's a spy he's a spider he's a [ __ ]
plumber
i wouldn't be able to wait to say i tell
you but i have to kill you
oh true that's a good line and meanest
yeah i mean
i mean it yeah yeah your bosses call you
in and they're like you have to stop
saying this
you can't do that anymore like that's
basically telling people you [ __ ]
you can't kill people in the united
states we have to ship them to gitmo
first
[Laughter]
i think a dream role because i could
definitely never be a spy they'd be like
we can see you you're not hiding behind
anything nikki
we see you walking in right now i would
want to play a spy
i think like a whole sexy angelina jolie
thing oh i think i could do that
so role playing that's fun yeah yes role
playing acting
sexual role-playing okay i like that all
of it
everything i want to pretend that i'm sp
that would be actually
nikki banks actually will work for that
nikki begs the spy
blades is still a dope enough name that
sounds like a different [ __ ] emperor
mickey bangs is a spy name nikki plays
this doesn't sound like a person who's
[ __ ] i don't know it doesn't
i don't think she's [ __ ] anything
nikki blades sounds like someone who
will
cut you you're gross she's like the
knife she's
nice uh border of some sort like she's
she's i definitely can be like a
superhero marvel character or something
like that
i'd probably be a villain i don't think
they would cast me as like a nice person
like she looks sweet
no she's i'm killing everybody i'm
cutting your head off that's true it's
like a villain's name
yeah oh i think it would be good yeah
[Music]
yeah
[Music]